foreign
[Music]
was to feel like a part of this family I
thought maybe my wedding would be a
chance to reconnect
ing I see now that maybe we were never
really connected
it's real shame on it
says oh my God have you seen this
invitation are you going to the wedding
Eloise is our half sister which means we
can half-ass the relationship
my rich sister chose to stay in London
and shove fish and chips up her butt
that's not how you eat them
is nice my company upgraded me very cool
country mouse I figured that everyone in
business class was going to be hot and
mean like you they got Paddington on
this flight
stink
[Music]
my sister's the worst thank you for
coming to England to my nuptials she's
like netaporte and I'm like Nordstrom
Rack Alice the line is spelling you bet
it is Mom she sounds like a monster so
lovely having you all here only 72 hours
until the big eye too oh my God Alice
I'm nine I think I just had some bad
chicken I have any chicken
it's wonderful being here with my
children and all their friends you know
he's not my friend you know I support
you excuse me sir yes he's my son what's
happening and they do sex things it's
a-okay with me and I'm proud
I'm getting married
from this moment forward you will behave
like a normal family who is here to
happily celebrate a loved one's wedding
is that understood she's even prettier
when she's angry absolutely radiant
[Music]
at every wedding there are those people
everyone talk about after cousin Randy
no we're those people this time
Savage Mom
[Applause]
[Music]
let's begin
[Music]